chaque année près de 6 millions de
sapins sont vendus en france dans les
hypermarchés chez les fleuristes en
pépinière mais traditionnellement dans
les années 60
certains allaient directement le
chercher dans la forêt malheureusement
cette année au coeur la période
précédant les grandes réjouissances
annuelles aura été celle de la douleur
au tous les petits arbres qui bouge avec
tom difficulté sur les bancs de l'école
in poland l'abattage sauvage de sapins
est interdite et sanctionnée et en
parallèle sa culture est encouragée le
voyage commence à dos d'homme mais pour
voyager plus commodément on va tâcher
aux petits sapins ses branches suivant
une technique éprouvée une région
française va vite devenir le numéro un
de la production
la bourgogne et plus précisément le
morvan exemple en 1968
en ce moment vous êtes en plein boom bah
oui est en train de de ficeler
d'expédier des quantités de sapins de
noël que les battre rayant d'exportation
leur premièrement la france et ensuite
l'étranger président afrique noire
l'afrique du sud l'afrique du nord
encore un pur l'amérique et dernièrement
nous avons eu des demandes de moscou
la progression de la culture du sapin
devient exponentielle une culture
intensive utilisant des produits
phytosanitaires conséquences dans les
années 2000 les premiers scandale
explose l'eau de certaines communes du
morvan est impropre à la consommation
on n'y a retrouvé des pesticides comme
le glyphosate la culture des sapins de
noël est alors pointé du doigt mais le
producteur numéro un de la région s'en
défendent et aucune
seulement aucune expérience n'a pu
prouver qu'avec toutes les études qui
ont été faites depuis 2000 que le sapin
de noël avait été à l'origine de
pollutions aux particules hier est
avérée en février 2002 pourtant cette
étude menée conjointement par le parc du
morvan la drass bourgogne et
l'université a mis en évidence
l'existence d'une relation entre sapins
de noël et pollution la relation est pas
direct et
complètement général mais on a pu
montrer quand même que quand il y avait
des cultures de sapins de noël sur le
bassin versant
on retrouvait dans certains cas une
contamination
depuis d'autres scandales sanitaires
dans la région ont relancé le débat et
dernièrement une pétition pour interdire
les pesticides a été lancée par des
riverains
[Musique]